there's a whole category of ASMR videos
called roleplay ASMR the person in the
video plays a character that you can
pretend to interact with I'm gonna try
it
ASMR youtuber good night moon did a
video where she pretends she's talking
to you at a Christmas Eve party
maybe I should tried to talk back to her
see if I can get into this I think we're
at the party hi hi no feelings okay I
feel pretty good what's wrong yeah
what yeah I'm right there with you right
there with me you feel good why the [ __ ]
did you just say I can't even [ __ ]
understand you so you've just been
hanging out here by the fire yeah I'm
hanging out here by the fire that's why
do you mind if I hang out with you I
would love it I know I even talks to me
here yeah it's it's great to spend time
with everyone but it's also nice to get
away from it for a minute right and
breathe okay anything to drink I would
love to could you just stop talking so
fast I mean she'd that even in listening
my answer she's not listening at all you
ever heard of Brooklyn ASMR no you
listen to this
alright how it would only two shows left
is so much to talk about
did you know that Sarah is oscar-worthy
he got ready futures at the time yeah I
wanted it is better when she whispers it
truly is just got way hotter Dimond amsr
acts like a cashier ringing up your
christmas purchases you want to hear
that what is wrong people aren't having
any experiences at all and whose
whispering at the cash register
maybe we should do a whole Charlotte
what is he shopping at the library did
you have any yeah I did some trouble
good
yeah I think eventually master boys who
whispers at a store that doesn't make
sense
you don't whisper at a store in the I
don't want cash register line and the
checkout line you got a sexy voice you
should be doing this for I couldn't do
this
I'm not going to contribute to the
demise of America I wonder what it is
but I feel like it's supposed to be
sexual I don't know I'd rather just jerk
off to porn this doesn't get me off and
they don't whisper important